what would you do if you walked in on
Geo making only fans content when I was
earlier 20s I probably [ __ ] pissed at
my age now like what the [ __ ] happened
why do you have to do this in secret I
would have said yes right off the bat
you would actually be okay with it me
and David been trying to get her ass on
only fans for like three years well You
Gotta Throw David in there make it all
weird people's gonna be a manager that's
not a bit that's like you really wanted
her to do it when uh cat came on and she
explained she was making like 300 G's a
month
such a good cash grab even if we just do
it for a short amount of time people
don't think Kim K and think I was just
sucking on Ray J's I do
you feel like you sympathize because you
were a delinquent I do probably
sympathize and if you're not breaking
the law and if it's extremely lucrative
I think there's less and less ego I
guess not why watching my wife get
[ __ ] it's like oh that was just my ego
why what about you you disagree I'll do
the videos over